welcome to this video playing gamez a
dragon 70 medic Kashian from from Los
Angeles ok hmm maybe player fianchetto
type of set up the double fianchetto
very solid way to to play as wide but it
has some it has some drop of poison in
it ok so it's going for green Felton
type of setup like a combination of the
ground fault and the Slav
yeah this is a very healthy setup like
puts all the prawns on light squares
after he has some traded not sure about
age five really want to attack him
yeah well still blacks position is very
solid even if he now has traded to the
h-bomb okay I can take click win g
Quincy three check check so you're ok
yes let's play the service end game here
or queen this middle game it's still I'm
slightly more comfortable for Wyatt it's
not much but i can try to do something
on the queenside while black is
basically am not having any active play
on his own
yeah it's fairly typical ready stuff
with before
yeah I wonder about them about the
center however i can if i should play
deform d43 expand them yeah maybe i
should do that d fried III takes away
the year five and see five squares for
the night yeah it's really bizarre she
really trying to to meet me on the H
file without Queens but it's really hard
to believe okay maybe I'm maybe I'm he's
arguing that this is a defensive set up
on the fifth rank here maybe
want to put it on d3 so that 95 can
become an can become an idea nitey for
this f3 so the moment he plays Rock agh
I probably go yeah whatever and probably
play a bit don't understand any of his
moves that's really really bizarre f3 93
m with 92 and this kind of checkmate
idea funny
but still I cannot believe in it how can
this be a be any good I mean this is a
totally solid structure
okay Bishop h3 what are you doing
against that
rooke g5 this f form maybe you can fight
on with kingdom to the rook edge aid
after that
I but I have kept f4 look h8 look aged
eight now that if i take it rook takes
actually that's not totally clear ready
amazingly enough that's not totally
clear
ff-for age eight isn't that something
after that now maybe that's really not
so clear
maybe that's not so clear so it's
totally strange but
okay just going from a later b4 b5 I I
feel like I have I haven't played this
optimally because this was so weird
those misplaced pieces all the way
you will probably play 93 no matter what
yeah yeah but I can play a 4 here I am
this was was a pre move that was not
workin out too well okay if I can can i
play be five year 94 takes on c6 am
check check here black resigns yeah I
still feel like I should have one roll
about here with with those totally weird
pieces here around here I'm pretty
confident that this was ok but maybe c5
was the best this was actually the best
continuation according to the computer
only here I should have played before me
yet lame with with a big advantage
interesting yeah with or maybe take with
the rook actually this is this is strong
this is strong that the party on b7 is
just falling yeah this is this is the
real deal I didn't see that this is this
is much stronger okay i played this this
prophylactic type of move and still
before I strong but here yeah I missed
this route before it's much much
stronger yeah I just played this
automatic recapture and thought okay I
go b5 and his rook is out of play but he
really has this counter play here with
the sacrifice okay when this is much
much stronger I threatened on b7 with a
check and this is just just a directly
winning I guess
check look at this just here takes c6 if
he takes here yeah the computer is just
saying wide wins but this still looks
tricky to me in a blitz game doesn't the
FES a ton of check cm well maybe okay so
let's check how it went yeah here he
only expected that the capture here
which I should have played actually and
now G for a beehive I was ahead this
idea but he could have continued with 92
check attacking the rook hmm but ok you
play at pier to enter this pre move so
it was quite funny yet he I'm winning
again so pretty much yeah probably the
right result but with some adventures ok
thanks for watching